Cette vidéo est destinée en priorité aux
élèves de prépa HEC,
mais si ça n’est pas votre cas,
ne passez pas votre chemin pour autant,
car vous pouvez aussi y trouver un véritable
intérêt.
Cette vidéo peut vous apporter quelque chose
à vous aussi
si vous cherchez à améliorer la qualité
de votre rédaction
et à développer votre capacité à synthétiser
de l’information.
Ce que je vais faire,
c’est commenter dans le détail
une copie de contraction
- c’est-à-dire un résumé de texte -
qui a été notée 20
au concours d’entrée à HEC de 2017.
D’ailleurs, le candidat a été admis à
HEC.
Vous pouvez télécharger le sujet et la copie
du candidat,
en cliquant sur le lien dans la description.
Et vous pouvez regarder la vidéo sans prendre
de notes,
parce que je vous donne également
MES notes de commentaire
avec le sujet et la copie.
Comme ça, vous êtes tranquille.
Enfin, posez-moi toutes vos questions
dans les commentaires
je m’engage à répondre à chacune d’entre
elles.
Alors, maintenant,
petite explication pour les non initiés :
l’épreuve dite de « contraction »
consiste à résumer un texte assez ardu de
5-6 pages
en 400 mots,
plus ou moins 5 pourcent
- c’est-à-dire plus ou moins 20 mots.
L’énoncé de l’épreuve,
c’était plus précisément :
« Résumez en quatre cents mots plus ou moins
5 % (soit 380 - 420 mots),
le texte suivant,
en vous attachant à mettre en valeur les
idées essentielles
et les articulations de la pensée de l’auteur.
»
Et puis en dessous il est aussi demandé de
compter les mots,
de rester impersonnel,
d’écrire clairement,
et bien sûr la calculette et l’iPhone sont
interdits.
Voilà voilà,
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur les conventions
de l’exercice,
Google est votre ami !
Alors, encore une fois,
téléchargez le sujet,
la copie de l'élève,
et même mes notes de commentaire
en cliquant sur le lien dans la description,
parce que vous allez en avoir besoin pour
me suivre !
Bon, pour autant,
je ne vais pas non plus vous demander de lire
le texte en entier
- même si vous pouvez le faire -
Je vais vous le présenter rapidement,
et puis je ferai surtout des remarques de
forme,
sans revenir dans le détail du texte initial.
Je le signalerai quand même,
si des idées essentielles manquent,
ou si des idées retenues ne sont pas essentielles,
mais ça ne constituera pas le coeur de mon
commentaire.
Mon objectif,
c’est surtout d’évaluer l’efficacité
du texte final.
Et tout à la fin de la vidéo,
je dirai si je suis d’accord avec le correcteur,
puis je répondrai à la question :
comment avoir 20 en contraction ?
Alors, le texte du sujet, maintenant,
c’est un extrait d’un essai du philosophe
assez connu François Jullien ;
et dans cet extrait,
il compare les stratégies militaires
et les stratégies du discours,
à partir de la pensée chinoise,
mais aussi de la pensée occidentale.
Je résume très rapidement :
il explique tout d’abord les caractéristiques
et les concepts profonds de la stratégie
militaire chinoise ;
il montre ensuite que la stratégie grecque
repose elle sur des principes inverses,
qui s’expliquent en partie par la conception
du discours dans la Cité grecque ;
enfin, il étend cette intuition
- la racine rhétorique de la stratégie militaire
-
à la civilisation chinoise.
Encore une fois,
n’oubliez pas de télécharger le sujet
et la copie
en cliquant sur le lien dans la description,
si vous voulez vraiment me suivre.
Allez, c’est parti :
Je me mets dans les habits du correcteur.
On commence par voir la première impression
qu’a probablement produite la copie.
Alors, l’écriture est plutôt propre.
Ça n’est pas de la grande calligraphie,
mais honnêtement c’est très lisible.
On peut peut-être regretter
que ça ne soit pas plus aéré.
Le candidat aurait pu sauter quelques lignes
tout au début,
et puis aussi espacer les paragraphes.
Le décompte des mots est bien présent :
les slashs dans le texte tous les 50 mots,
et puis le nombre dans la marge.
Je passe à la page suivante.
Je descends.
Les paragraphes font à peu près la même
taille
- à vue d’oeil une quinzaine de lignes
-
donc l’équilibre global du texte semble
bon.
On arrive au décompte final.
413 mots : c’est nickel.
Tu le sais peut-être :
il est recommandé d’écrire au moins 410
mots,
sinon le correcteur se dira qu’il manque
probablement
une ou plusieurs idées essentielles.
Donc, 413 c’est parfait.
Alors, mini conclusion sur la première impression
:
c’est globalement positif parce que
les consignes sont respectées,
le nombre de mots est bon,
et c’est bien lisible.
Il aurait pu aérer un peu,
mais bon ça n’est pas grave.
Je chipote un peu,
mais ce n’est pas parce qu’elle a été
notée 20
qu’il ne faut pas critiquer la copie.
Elle ne fait pas forcément non plus un bon
modèle.
Bien sûr,
la première impression ne permet pas de deviner
que la copie mérite une note excellente ;
la seule chose qu’on sache, à ce stade,
c’est que c’est un travail à priori sérieux.
Pour en savoir plus,
il faut lire la copie dans le détail.
Je vais donc la commenter paragraphe par paragraphe.
C’est parti.
Première phrase :
« Les stratèges chinois,
dont l’influence s’étend au reste de
la pensée chinoise,
ont insisté sur un principe majeur :
éviter la bataille frontale. »
Il commence son paragraphe par évoquer la
caractéristique principale de la stratégie
chinoise.
C’est bien sur le fond, puisque c’est
évidemment une idée essentielle du texte
source,
qui traite des caractéristiques de la stratégie
chinoise.
Et puis c’est bien aussi sur la forme, parce
que pour qu’un paragraphe soit très clair,
il faut que la première phrase en expose
l’idée principale - et puis les suivantes
la développent.
La phrase en elle-même est très claire.
Les mots ne sont pas compliqués.
Ma seule mini réticence, c’est que ça
aurait pu être encore plus direct : la proposition
« dont l’influence s’étend au reste
de la pensée chinoise » n’est pas hyper
utile, et elle coupe le rythme de la phrase.
Moi j’aurais écrit plus simplement : « Les
stratèges chinois ont fondé leurs théories
sur un principe majeur : éviter la bataille
frontale. »
De manière générale, c’est mieux de se
limiter à un seul verbe conjugué dans la
première phrase d’un paragraphe.
Mais sinon la phrase est efficace, donc je
passe à la suivante.
« Il faut, au contraire, savoir anticiper
l’adversaire pour bloquer sa stratégie
et ainsi vaincre sans avoir à combattre.
»
Alors, sur le fond, il précise l’idée
de la phrase suivante - donc c’est cohérent.
Le lien est bien mis en évidence - c’est
un lien logique d’opposition - avec la locution
« au contraire ».
Sur la forme, c’est plutôt efficace - on
comprend bien - mais il y a quelques petites
imprécisions lexicales.
C’est plutôt la stratégie adverse, et
non pas l’adversaire, qui doit être anticipée
;
et puis « bloquer la stratégie » n’est
pas terrible - j’aurais plutôt écrit quelque
chose comme « entraver ses manoeuvres ».
Mais bon, encore une fois, c’est efficace
parce qu’on comprend facilement.
Donc je continue.
« Le bon général maîtrise alors aussi
bien l’affrontement direct qu’indirect,
d’abord dans l’aspect purement militaire,
mais également dans la stratégie qu’il
sait dissimuler pour surprendre son adversaire.
»
Cette phrase précise la précédente : elle
dit comment se traduit le principe stratégique
à l’échelle du général.
L’adverbe « alors » montre bien qu’il
s’agit, sur le plan logique, d’une conséquence.
Pour autant, je ne trouve pas la phrase super
claire.
C’est surtout la distinction de l’aspect
purement militaire et de l’aspect stratégique
que je ne trouve pas claire sur le fond, même
si elle est faite clairement sur la forme.
Et puis je trouve que la proposition relative
« qu’il sait dissimuler pour surprendre
son adversaire » est hors-sujet par rapport
à l’idée générale de la phrase.
Il aurait dû se limiter à l’idée de la
maîtrise des deux types d’affrontement.
Il aurait par exemple pu écrire : « Le bon
général maîtrise alors aussi bien l’affrontement
direct qu’indirect, au niveau de la préparation
comme de la mise en pratique ».
Là, parler de « préparation » ça permet
d’éviter la redondance du terme « stratégie
», qui risque d’être pas mal répété
dans cette contraction.
Bon, en tout cas, première phrase pas géniale,
clairement moins efficace que les précédentes.
Je continue.
« Cette logique tire son fondement du fait
que le rapport direct, lorsqu’une chose
en cause une autre, est plus faible que le
rapport indirect où la chose, simplement
en puissance, en cause une autre, parce que,
n’étant pas réalisée, la chose est impossible
à bloquer. »
Bon, je me suis levé en forme ce matin, mais
là je commence à avoir mal à la tête.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’il est allé faire dans
cette galère ?
La phrase est bien évidemment trop compliquée.
Et puis, sur la forme, l’expression « tire
son fondement du fait que » n’est pas géniale,
le nom commun « chose » et le verbe « causer
» sont répétés ; et on retrouve le verbe
« bloquer » (il était déjà dans les paragraphes
précédents), verbe qui en plus n’est pas
super.
Moi j’aurais plutôt écrit quelque chose
comme « La supériorité fondamentale d’une
stratégie indirecte repose sur l’impossibilité
d’empêcher la menace ou la dissuasion,
qui ne sont pas des actions effectives. »
Bon, comme la phrase n’est pas assez claire,
j’en ai oublié ses qualités.
Elle est bien liée à la précédente par
l’adjectif démonstratif « cette », et
elle la développe en en expliquant le fondement
théorique - mais elle l’explique mal.
Bon, c’est dommage, le paragraphe ne se
termine pas très bien.
Petite conclusion pour ce premier paragraphe
:
il est globalement efficace.
Il expose bien des idées essentielles du
texte source ;
il est bien cohérent,
avec la première phrase qui expose l’idée
générale,
et le reste du paragraphe qui la développe
;
c’est fluide :
chaque phrase est liée à la précédente,
et il y a quasiment un lien logique par phrase.
enfin, il n’y a pas de fautes d’orthographe.
C’est globalement clair,
mais la dernière phrase fait un peu tâche,
et j’ai souligné quelques petits défauts
ici ou là.
On voit donc déjà que cette copie n’est
pas parfaite,
alors même qu’elle a été notée 20.
Allez, je passe au paragraphe suivant.
Première phrase : « Je voudrais interroger
cette conception en la comparant à celles
des Grecs qui s’affrontaient en batailles
frontales. »
Alors, ce qui saute aux yeux, c’est qu’il
se permet de recourir à la première personne
du singulier.
Je le dis sans détour : il ne faut pas faire
ça !
Je rappelle que l’énoncé stipule que l’exercice
« doit rester impersonnel dans le fond comme
dans la forme ».
J’ai lu une vingtaine de contractions notées
entre 17 et 20 au concours d’entrée à
HEC en 2017, et c’est bien la seule où
le candidat se permet de faire ça.
Donc, encore une fois, c’est à éviter,
même si là le correcteur a été tolérant.
Il a probablement été tolérant parce que
la phrase est à la fois très pertinente
- elle délivre exactement la deuxième grande
idée du texte source - et elle est aussi
ultra claire.
Elle oppose très simplement la conception
chinoise à la conception occidentale.
Donc bon, avec cette efficacité de style,
il peut y avoir un effet de compensation.
On jugera par la suite.
Je continue.
« V. Hanson a expliqué que ce rapport frontal
était la conséquence d’un choix délibéré
: une bataille rapide où le résultat est
clair. »
Il y a encore quelque chose qui saute aux
yeux : il cite un auteur.
Ça n’est pas rédhibitoire parce qu’il
ne s’agit pas de l’auteur du texte source,
mais il est fortement recommandé de ne pas
le faire.
La consigne de base, c’est de ne sélectionner
une information qu’à la condition qu’elle
ait la force d’un argument et qu’elle
soit essentielle dans le texte source.
Je sais qu’il faut rendre à César ce qui
est à César, mais là c’est inutile de
mentionner l’auteur de la thèse.
Sur le fond, c’est toujours pareil : elle
précise la phrase précédente, elle en donne
la cause, donc c’est bien cohérent.
Sur la forme, elles sont liées l’une à
l’autre par la locution « ce rapport frontal
».
Sinon, la phrase est très claire, avec un
vocabulaire très simple.
Moi j’aurais plutôt écrit : « Ce rapport
frontal est la conséquence d’une préférence
pour une bataille rapide au résultat incontestable.
»
Je passe à la phrase suivante :
« Toute stratégie pour perturber l’adversaire
était rejetée, pas parce que les Grecs ignoraient
la stratégie de l’affrontement indirect
mais parce qu’ils ne se sont pas concentrés
dessus. »
Là, il n’y a pas de lien explicite avec
la phrase précédente, mais on comprend bien
qu’elle en développe l’idée : elle dit
que les Grecs se sont focalisés sur les stratégies
directes.
Donc c’est bien cohérent.
Sur la forme, j’ai plusieurs réticences.
J’aurais plutôt parlé de « stratégie
de perturbation de l’adversaire ».
Il faut écrire « non pas parce que », et
NON PAS « pas parce que » qui relève d’un
style oral.
Le mot « stratégie » est répété dans
la phrase.
Il faut une virgule avant « mais », pour
indiquer la pause de lecture.
Enfin, si le verbe « ignorer » est à l’imparfait,
alors le verbe « concentrer » doit l’être
aussi.
On pourrait écrire « …parce qu’ils la
délaissaient volontairement. ».
Donc bonne phrase sur le fond, mais améliorable
sur la forme.
Je continue.
« Les travaux de M. Détienne conduisent
même à penser que c’est une conception
générale des Grecs qui lie leurs principes
militaires à leur système militaire. »
Bon, je rappelle qu’il ne faut pas faire
de référence, je ne reviens pas sur cette
consigne.
Le lien avec la phrase précédente est évident
: c’est un lien logique d’addition signalé
par l’adverbe « même ».
Pour autant, l’idée est mal exprimée.
L’idée précise du texte source, c’est
que la préférence des Grecs pour les stratégies
directes découle d’une conception plus
générale, une conception qu’on retrouve
aussi dans le système politique grec.
Je vous renvoie au sujet de l'épreuve si
vous voulez clarifier ça.
Sur la forme, maintenant, c’est plutôt
efficace.
La nuance du texte source, le fait qu’il
s’agisse d’une hypothèse, est bien retranscrite
avec la locution « conduire à penser ».
Et puis les mots sont simples et bien choisis.
Phrase suivante : « Retrouve-t-on aussi ce
choix de l’affrontement direct au sein du
débat dans la Cité ? »
Ce qui saute aux yeux, c’est qu’il s’agit
d’une question.
Alors, moi je déconseille les questions en
contraction, parce que c’est compliqué
à faire.
Mais bon, ça a des avantages : ça permet
notamment de fluidifier le texte, de le redynamiser.
Ici, la question revient à interroger dans
le détail l’hypothèse exposée par la
phrase précédente - c’est comme si on
demandait : « Est-ce que c’est bien vérifié
? ».
Sur la forme, c’est parfaitement clair - rien
à dire.
Donc je continue.
« Le débat se construit par un échange
d’arguments évalués par l’auditoire
qui finalement vote. »
Cette phrase déclarative répond tout simplement
à la question.
L’idée - l’affrontement direct par les
arguments - est juste, rien à dire sur le
fond.
Sur la forme, la phrase est très claire,
mais pas très élégante - notamment la proposition
relative « qui finalement vote ».
J’aurais plutôt écrit : « Le débat consiste
en échange d’arguments qui forge l’opinion
politique, et donc le vote de l’audience.
»
Mais bon, la phrase est quand même relativement
efficace.
Je passe à la suivante : « Il s’agit,
comme lors des batailles, de déterminer rapidement
et clairement le vainqueur. »
Avec la locution « il s’agit de », elle
précise clairement la précédente en donnant
la finalité implicite du débat dans la cité
grecque.
Donc c’est cohérent.
Sur la forme, elle est extrême claire.
On peut remarquer que les deux dernières
phrases sont très claires notamment parce
qu’elles sont courtes. En effet, plus une
phrase est longue, plus le risque qu’elle
ne soit pas suffisamment claire est important.
Je continue : « C’est sans doute une des
causes qui explique pourquoi la Chine n’a
pas cette tradition du vote, équivalent à
un affrontement direct. »
Le lien avec la phrase précédente est clairement
établi avec la locution « c’est ».
Là le candidat évoque une conséquence de
la finalité implicite du vote : comme le
processus du vote est une manière directe
de désigner un vainqueur, il ne s’est pas
imposé dans la tradition chinoise.
Sur la forme, c’est bien clair, mais pas
très élégant.
La construction en double proposition subordonnée
- avec « qui explique » et « pourquoi » - n’est
pas super.
J’aurais plutôt écrit quelque chose comme
« Cette finalité implicite est probablement
une des causes de l’absence du vote dans
la tradition chinoise. »
Mais bon, je reconnais que j’aime bien chipoter.
La phrase est quand même très claire.
Je continue : « Cela montre également tout
le caractère culturel du vote. »
Lien logique d’addition avec l’adverbe
« également » - c’est très bien.
Sur le fond, il s’agit d’une induction
par rapport à l’idée précédente, parce
que le candidat tire une idée générale
d’une idée précise : de l’absence du
vote dans la tradition chinoise - ce qui est
factuel - il induit le caractère culturel
du vote.
Bref, c’est précis tout ça - mais ça
prouve bien la cohérence de la phrase par
rapport à la précédente et par rapport
au paragraphe.
Sur la forme, elle est encore plus courte
que les précédentes, et donc, conformément
aux probabilités, très claire.
Conclusion pour ce deuxième paragraphe :
on retrouve les qualités du premier :
les idées sont bien sélectionnées ;
c’est très clair, très cohérent, et très
fluide.
Mais il y a quand même quelques imprécisions
de fond
et défauts de forme.
Et puis surtout une véritable prise de risque
:
le candidat écrit à la première personne
du singulier ;
il cite des auteurs ;
et il pose une question.
Ça fait quand même beaucoup, je trouve.
Mais bon,
le correcteur a probablement estimé
que c’était largement compensé par la
grande clarté du paragraphe,
notamment à la fin,
où les phrases sont plus courtes et plus
directes.
Voyons voir si le candidat continue sur sa
lancée
dans le paragraphe suivant.
Première phrase : « Il me semble
que cette opposition est également présente
dans les conceptions logiques des deux cultures.
»
Bon, le candidat se permet encore de ne pas
respecter la consigne d’impersonnalité
donnée par l’énoncé.
D’ailleurs ça l’autorise à utiliser
l’indicatif ; sans le pronom personnel « me
», il faudrait écrire « soit également
présente. »
Mais bon, c’est un petit détail.
Le mieux, c’est de rester totalement impersonnel.
Sur le fond, on retrouve bien l’idée essentielle
du texte source, selon laquelle l’opposition
entre les stratégies directes et indirectes
exprime une différence culturelle fondamentale.
Pour autant, cette idée générale n’est
pas exprimée très clairement.
Il faut préciser qu’il s’agit de l’opposition
entre les deux types de stratégies.
Et puis « conceptions logiques » est beaucoup
trop précis - la logique, c’est le processus
qui permet de passer rigoureusement d’une
idée à la suivante.
Il fallait plutôt parler de paradigmes intellectuels.
C’est un détail, mais l’adverbe « également
» est répété - or, il n’est pas nécessaire
d’utiliser un connecteur logique dans la
première phrase d’un paragraphe.
Au total, moi j’aurais plutôt écrit quelque
chose comme : « L’opposition entre les
stratégies grecque et chinoise reflète la
profonde différence entre deux paradigmes
intellectuels culturels. »
Phrase suivante : « Lors d’un débat grec,
deux idées s’opposent par des arguments
assimilables à des unités mathématiques
aisément quantifiables. »
Là, il développe l’idée précédente
en évoquant d'abord la conception culturelle
grecque telle qu’elle s’exprime dans le
débat.
Donc c’est cohérent.
Sur la forme, je trouve que c’est parfait
: c’est précis, c’est très clair, et
les mots sont justes.
Rien à dire, donc je passe à la phrase suivante.
« Le vainqueur est celui qui en accumule
le plus, comme le nombre d’hommes entraîne
la victoire lors du combat. »
Cette phrase précise la fin de la précédente,
avec le pronom « en » qui renvoie aux « unités
mathématiques aisément quantifiables ».
Donc c’est évidemment cohérent.
Alors, on comprend très bien la comparaison
entre l’accumulation des arguments dans
un débat et celle des soldats dans une bataille,
mais ça n’est pas dit très élégamment.
Moi j’aurais plutôt écrit : « Le vainqueur
est celui qui en accumule le plus, de la même
manière que la taille des troupes est un
facteur décisif de la victoire militaire.
»
Je continue : « En Chine le débat est également
conçu en tant qu’affrontement. »
Petite remarque préliminaire : il faut une
virgule après « En Chine », pour marquer
la pause de lecture.
Je chipote peut-être, mais les correcteurs
se plaignent des négligences de ponctuation
dans les rapports de jury.
La phrase est liée à la précédente par
l’adverbe « également » - qui a déjà
été utilisé deux trois fois d’ailleurs
- donc c’est un lien logique d’addition.
Alors, sur la forme il n’y a rien à dire,
parce que la phrase est courte et très claire.
D’ailleurs, varier les phrases longues et
les phrases courtes c’est une bonne manière
de dynamiser un texte.
Sur le fond, en revanche, ça ne va pas, parce
que l’enjeu du paragraphe c’est de montrer
que l’opposition des stratégies militaires
est le reflet d’une opposition intellectuelle
culturelle.
Or, là l’élève fait le parallèle : il
dit grosso modo « c’est pareil en Chine
».
Il fallait plutôt écrire quelque chose comme
: « En Chine, le débat est conçu comme
une forme différente d’affrontement. »
Je passe à la phrase suivante : « Là encore,
la stratégie chinoise y est celle de l’affrontement
indirect. »
Cette phrase précise la précédente, puisqu’elle
révèle de quelle forme d’affrontement
il s’agit.
La locution « Là encore » est juste, mais
on ne perçoit pas assez facilement que le
lien d’addition concerne l’idée de l’affrontement
indirect dans la stratégie militaire chinoise
- qui est exprimée dans les paragraphes précédents
- et non pas la phrase suivante.
En réalité, cette phrase s’oppose à la
précédente qui rapproche, elle, les conceptions
du débat en Occident et en Chine.
En gardant la phrase précédente, il fallait
donc plutôt écrire : « Dans le détail,
cependant, cette conception présente la même
préférence pour le biais que la stratégie
militaire chinoise. »
Mais bon, sur la forme, c’est quand même
très clair, ce qui s’explique en bonne
partie par le fait que la phrase est plutôt
courte.
Il y a juste la répétition du terme « affrontement
», mais ça n’est pas très grave.
Je continue : « En n’exprimant jamais clairement
une idée, le débatteur chinois n’en a
aucune à défendre et peut aisément manipuler
son adversaire, comme avec la stratégie militaire
quand elle n’existe qu’en puissance. »
Alors, cette phrase développe ce qu’est
l’affrontement indirect dans la tradition
chinoise du débat - donc elle est cohérente.
C’est très clair et très efficace jusqu’à
« manipuler son adversaire ».
Petit détail : j’aurais ajouté « ainsi
» après « peut » pour bien signaler la
conséquence.
Sinon, ma réticence, c’est que la comparaison
avec la stratégie militaire aurait pu être
exprimée plus clairement.
J’aurais par exemple écrit : « …de la
même manière que le stratège militaire
corrompt les anticipations de son adversaire.
»
Mais sinon, c’est globalement clair.
Je passe à la dernière phrase de la contraction
: « Les conceptions logiques sont donc déterminantes
culturellement. »
Alors, c’est un peu la conclusion partielle
de tout le paragraphe : elle en reprend d’ailleurs
l’idée de la première phrase, qui en était
l’introduction partielle.
Du coup, sur le fond, cette phrase n’apporte
rien, et de ce point de vue-là, elle est
critiquable - pas besoin de faire un résumé
dans le résumé.
La conjonction « donc » fait artificiel,
parce que la phrase n’est pas une conséquence
de la précédente.
Toujours sur le fond, l’idée n’est pas
très compréhensible : qu’est-ce que ça
veut dire « déterminantes culturellement
» ?
Et puis il répète l’expression « conception
logique » qui ne m’avait déjà pas convaincu
dans la première phrase.
Je pense qu’il veut dire que les paradigmes
intellectuels qui sous-tendent les stratégies
militaires comme les stratégies du discours
sont propres aux civilisations.
Mais bon, ça n’est pas au correcteur de
deviner.
Au total, cette dernière phrase est plutôt
ratée, elle ne sert pas à grand chose.
Alors, conclusion pour cet ultime paragraphe
:
on retrouve encore les grandes qualités des
deux premiers paragraphes,
à savoir la clarté, la cohérence, et la
fluidité.
Mais on retrouve aussi les travers du paragraphe
précédent :
le non respect de la consigne d’impersonnalité,
des imprécisions sur le fond,
et puis des fragments de phrase
qui auraient pu être plus clairs.
Enfin, ce paragraphe ne commence
et ne finit pas très bien :
l’idée n’est pas claire dans la première
phrase,
et la dernière est une sorte de conclusion
inutile.
Ça, c’est pas super.
Bon, je lui ai trouvé pas mal de défauts
à cette contraction,
donc je la noterais comment ?
Alors, faisons un petit bilan des forces
et des faiblesses de la copie.
Les forces sont assez évidentes :
les idées essentielles du texte source sont
présentes,
et le plan de la contraction reprend grosso
modo
le résumé que j’ai proposé dans l’introduction
;
c’est très cohérent,
c’est-à-dire que les phrases et les idées
sont toutes connectées,
qu’elles s’enchaînent bien,
et que la contraction constitue un tout efficacement
articulé ;
enfin, c’est très clair,
parce qu’on comprend presque toujours immédiatement
le propos.
Et puis je peux ajouter que je n’ai pas
trouvé de faute d’orthographe
en lisant pourtant la copie dans le détail.
Les faiblesses maintenant :
le candidat s’est affranchi de deux consignes
de base,
l’impersonnalité et l’absence de références
;
il y a quelques imprécisions sur le fond
certains fragments de phrase pourraient être
plus clairs,
et il y a quelques répétitions.
Bon, au total,
je ne vais pas faire la fine bouche :
c’est bien sûr une très bonne copie.
Mais est-ce qu’elle mérite vraiment 20
?
Pour ma part,
je n’ai pas eu, en la lisant, la sensation,
ce petit truc en plus qui émane de l’excellence.
J’ai lu des copies notées 20 que j’ai
trouvées meilleures,
et d’autres notées 17-18 du même niveau.
Donc cette copie,
je la noterais plutôt 17-18.
Et je trouve que les deux phrases à la forme
personnelle,
ça empêche de mettre 19-20,
parce que le principe de l’exercice,
c’est quand même de produire un résumé
aussi détaché que possible.
Pourquoi est-ce que le correcteur a tiré
la note à 20, lui ?
Parce qu’il a estimé que les grandes qualités
de forme
- clarté, cohérence, fluidité -
compensent très largement les défauts de
la copie.
Et puis j’imagine que c’est aussi dû
à des circonstances :
peut-être,
ou probablement que les copies avant et après
celle-ci dans le tas
étaient vraiment médiocres,
avec plein de fautes d’expression et d’orthographe,
etc.
et donc ça crée un effet de contraste
qui booste la note de cette copie.
Mais bon,
tant mieux pour le candidat !
Sa copie ne fait donc pas un modèle,
parce qu’elle est loin d’être parfaite,
mais on y retrouve tout de même les ingrédients
fondamentaux
pour atteindre l’excellence dans l’exercice.
Alors, comment avoir 20 en contraction ?
Il faut respecter toutes les consignes,
sélectionner rigoureusement les idées essentielles
dans le texte source,
et écrire de manière très très claire,
et très cohérente.
Ça y est : vous l’avez, la formule magique
!
Vous pouvez me poser toutes vos questions
en commentaires
et je m’engage à répondre à chacune d’entre
elles.
Pour rappel,
le sujet de l’épreuve,
la copie,
ET MÊME mes notes de commentaire sont disponibles
en cliquant sur le lien dans la description.
J’espère que ce commentaire de copie
va vous aider à progresser en contraction
sans vous prendre la tête.
Sur ce,
je vous souhaite
bon courage pour le travail !